Robert says, when are your optimal cold calling hours? Personally, mornings,
afternoons, evenings. So I'll tell you the times that seem like they're not the best.
And then everything else, I feel like it's pretty similar. Times that are not the best seem to be
like Monday morning. So seem like a little bit tough because everyone's trying to like get after
it. And then it seems like right around like, you know, 11 to one, because something like I can never
tell people eat lunch. Some people eat lunch at once. Some people eat lunch like really early.
So what I would recommend is like maybe try and avoid those times. And then everything else,
I just kind of watch. I actually have had really good luck calling business owners on Saturdays,
like believe it or not, because they're working. The ones that are working, not all of them will
be, but I'll bet that most of the people that are running ads, they've got someone or they or
someone else that they are paying is going to be answering the phone. Saturday, if you call me,
I'm talking about strategizing for my business. I'm talking about on my business, not in my
business. I've had a really good luck on Saturdays. I would just tell you the times that seem to be
hard is first thing in the morning, Mondays, and then like that 11 to one timeframe, just regular
days. Okay. Cause I just never know when they're doing lunch, just personal experience.